each year Microsoft Research hosts
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world including leading
scientists renowned experts in
technology book authors and leading
academics and makes videos of these
lectures freely available
well good afternoon it's my pleasure to
introduce mark superstein is the last
year PhD student at technion-israel
institute of technology and this mark
stock today would be on execution of
memory rom workloads on GPU we are
software manager thanks thanks a lot for
interaction thanks for having me here
it's a huge honor I know you guys are
very difficult to impress you have a lot
of nice stuff here going on but I'll try
so this work has been done in UC Davis
in early two thousand seven and then I
continued working on that in in Haifa in
the Technion and and in UC Davis it was
John Owens and nangel Patton who helped
me on that John Owens is the professor
in davis nib and of course my advisors
down geiger and the sub Shuster at the
Technium so um briefly so if you think
of memory demanding applications on GPUs
the best Red Cloud ever you can do on
GPU is when you have a lot of operations
per single memory access this is because
of the typical this is because of the
memory architecture on GPUs so this is
called higher if netic intensity now
this is the best workload you can get
and that's why you in this look in this
red cloud you would be able to get
maximum out of the GPU nice work load is
the one where you do have memory use
button so you probably can reuse your
memory in a certain way but this button
access button is known at the compile
time so typically for matrix
multiplication you do blocking in order
to fit your in computations to to cash
and the block size is usually deterrent
at the compile time so it's kind of hard
cord and it doesn't it doesn't depend on
the infant furnitures
so what you typically do you use this
crash pad memory on GPU in a clever way
so you prefetch the data that you're
going to use several times in order not
to get to the global memory every time
and by prefetching it you essentially
make it available to the computation on
cheap now the interesting thing is that
multiple threads work collaboratively on
the prefetch data then they switch the
set of data that are working on and go
on to the to another piece of data etc
etc the tough work load is when you
don't have this luxury of knowing memory
use burden at compile time and this is
the workload that we will be talking
about so in a nutshell we can think of
this software of this scratchpad memory
that is available to several threads on
GPU two blocks of threads on GPU as a
cache regular cash and although this is
not particularly you there are many
people who consider this as a cache and
say we do one step further and try to
analyze our workload as if it was a real
cash and also we are trying to build a
machinery to allow this cash to be
configured at runtime and by selecting
the appropriate cache policy depending
on the input which is optimal for a
specific input so in my talk today I
will describe our solution to this
particular problem on the example of
some product computations and I will
also show some old results that we had
since 2007 on g 80 and some new results
that we have on g2 on gtx 285 obviously
we do not have results infer me not yet
but I hopeful that we will and my I
briefly mentioned also the things that
we did with the super armor
supercomputer which has a 690 GPUs it's
kind of a cluster that has a lot of GPUs
and we used it for running it's very
large problems on thousands of CPUs and
120 GPUs so I will briefly mention what
we did there so in essence we have very
very simple performance model that we
can think of on GPU so we what we want
to do is to be able to analyze our
workload in advance without any actually
writing you any piece of code to know
what will be the best performance that
we can get if we do that in an optimal
way so essentially if the data is supply
if the data supply is fast enough to
keep all L us busy well this is CPU
bound workload and it's easy however in
other case on GPU you actually have to
ship your data and you saturate the
bandwidth and by saturating the
bandwidth you're limiting your
performance so can we actually evaluate
and do kind of a trivial you know
arithmetic stew know what is the maximum
that we're going to get well of course
because basically our expected
performance is going to be more or less
our it Matic intensity which is this
parameter which is algorithmic specific
number of operations / memory access
that we do x the bandwidth right and
then we just take minimum between the
magnetic intensity by bandwidth and the
best ALU performance we can get so this
is kind of very very simplistic model
but it turns out that when we just you
know take very very simple workload the
trivial one that is being used by in
video all over just to show kind of
trivial colonel this is just vector
multiplication so what you see from this
analysis is that they're at matok
intensity here is one third right we
have three operators we have three
memory accesses one variety to four ears
and one operation so for this arithmetic
intensity they expects the performance
that we going to get
is only seven gigaflops which is only
five percent of utilization of the card
of G 80 and for a more advanced card
with a 285 we would get slightly more
than that but it's it would still be
like two percent of the available ALU
capability of the GPU okay so its valve
gigaflops which is almost one percent
because this card provides teraflop of
of performance right so with this
simplistic model we already know this is
this workload is going to be very very
GPU an unfriendly you finally now if we
now think about the scratchpad as a cash
we can think of incorporating this into
the this simplistic analysis by
considering not the number of memory
accesses per operation but rather the
memory access cost right this is what we
do when we consider cache misses and
cache hits right so cash here is kind of
costs nothing Kashmir's costs the memory
access right and if we can formalize the
cache hit model for our application we
can think of the way to analyze the
workload that does consider shared
memory okay so for this case where we
have matrix multiplications there is a
oh and reuse without the cash our
Atlantic intensity would be only
constant would not depend on the input
and this way would be limited by this
very low utilization of GPU whereas for
a cached well only compulsory muses we
would get the workload that would become
CPU bound because it would depend on the
input parameters okay so it's kind of
perfect scaling this sense because the
more data we have the better performance
we can again okay so with this simple
model we already know that for a matrix
multiplication there is no way we would
be able to do that without using scratch
pad now I'll turn to the applique
asian that we are using to evaluate our
approach so the motivation for using
some products is interventions a very
large Basin probabilistic networks for
parametric genetic linkage analysis this
application allows geneticists to
analyze their data and find genetic
provoking genes so essentially this
computation is exponential in some input
parameters and that's why it may require
a lot of a lot of computational time so
what we want to do we would try to use
GPU for computing that now our other
approach is to use multiple distributed
computing environments or opportunistic
measurements and there is actually
working system that uses them but that's
not a subject so what it is if you can
think of some product as a reformulation
more generalized way to think of matrix
multiplication so what do we have here
is product of two matrices and
essentially this is the you know this is
just the the formula for each one of the
mantra of which on one of the values for
this resulting matrix now if we think of
X Y is that as variables over finite
domain then essentially a XZ and B Z Y
turn to be functions of these variables
and the you know the this functions map
from the discrete domain of x y is that
to the actual values that are part of
these mattresses so essential in this
way when we represent matrix product in
this way we can think of a XZ and B is
that why as being multiplied in some way
right and then marginalize or summarized
overshare dimension right so this is
just an abstraction for matrix
multiplication so what we do here and
this is essential to understand because
essentially this gives the idea of
random access to the input
so for this case what we have here is
that we have two vectors okay so a 0 0
and here 00 mean X Z and Z Y
respectively so what we do we kind of
compute all different permutations of
this too over where we fix all those
variables that not that are not shared
and compute different permutations of
the shared variables here okay so
essentially we get the product of all
different permutations over variable Z
when we fix X Y to be 0 then X Y to be 0
1 etc etc now this is the first part
this is the multiplication and the
second part is actually to take these
different parts and some over and if you
think what we do here is we sum over
different values that refer to different
values of Z right so we put this and
this this and this this is this and the
result is certainly exactly regular
matrix multiplication however the point
is here that now we can generalize
multiplication of multiple mattresses or
do some product of a set of functions
now general functions that cannot be
reduced to simple matrices and some over
the shared dimensions so if we have
three matrices like that and we sum over
w and y we may get it in two ways one
way is to generate this function over
four dimensions and then sum over w and
x aw and why this would require o of n
by four operations if the number of
values for each variable is n however
now we can use a distributive law and in
this way we would be able first to
compute this product and marginalize
over w and then take the result of this
one and marginalize over why this would
be much more computationally efficient
and this approach is called bucket
computations where you accidentally
split your input into buckets where you
first compute one back and then push the
output of this computation to the next
one and this way you say quite a lot so
even in this
computation you already save of n
operations right so in general case you
have a lot of functions and you sum over
some of the variables right
interestingly enough this is kind of
general presentation of a general
problem where you can substitute
summation x max mean a boolean or or an
multiplication you can substitute by
summation or boolean and and then you
get totally different problem from
totally different domain so but the
fundamental structure of the problem
remains the same and the fundamental
structure is to find the best order of
splitting things into buckets now what
I'm going to talk today is how to
accelerate these computations so let's
zoom in into one bucket what I want to
compute is the single bucket and I want
to compute it efficiently so I split my
input in a certain way and I won't zoom
in this particular subject but let's
assume I have some way of splitting
things into a bucket now I have one
bucket and I want to compute it so one
bucket is a set of functions
marginalized of a separate set of
variables okay I don't split it in more
buckets this is the basic thing so now
what I want to do is I want to take this
bucket computed on GPU and push the
output of this computations to the next
GPU invocation of the next kernel with
another perimeter and essentially this
computation forms command of a tree so
it's it's essentially pipeline okay so
now with this in mind if we do this
analysis that we did for simple matrix
multiply which is essentially as we've
seen is particular case of some product
the worst case where there is no reuse
I'm expecting to get advanced 22 x 1
plus number of functions which means
that if I have 10 functions in my bucket
I'm going to get only two flops
from this thing no matter what I do GPU
would give me only this performance
however if I do your scratch pad
in a certain way I'm going to get
significant improvement in the earlier
consumption alright so I hope I
convinced you that without the cash I
would not be able to improve this
performance ok so once we have that in
mind I want to zoom in a little bit just
to remind you how GPU is built so GPU
essentially is a copper stress of the
sits across pci bus ok these numbers may
be changing and increasing over time but
i'm in essential basics for the next two
years seem to bring rain so in order to
do any computation you first have to
pour your data to the GPU from cpu then
you invoke what's called Colonel the
trans on this ESPYs stream processors
and then this kernel the output of the
execution should be passed by over the
pci bus back to GP bay back to CP you
now have a look here there is no cash
right so this is kind of a rare thing
that we have to deal with you know in
simplistic representation of GPUs so
let's make it a little bit complex and
that's what Nvidia deed with their CUDA
architecture they said ok let's split
all these ESPYs into pieces and provide
for each set of SP is a little bit of
shared memory a little bit of on cheap
memory which is very fast and provides
huge bandwidth ok however this bandwidth
and this memory must be managed by the
software as a part of your kernel as a
part of their computations you have to
squeeze in cash logic right so if you do
that in an in structured way and use it
as a scratch pad indeed fine but we want
to do the analysis so we want to be a
real cash here right so how we do that
just trying to analyze the challenge
we're think that the typical cache aware
algorithm if you think of it when you
write something for GP for CPU you're
trying to implicitly avoid slow accesses
to to the memory right so you try to be
as local as you can be and essentially
you kind of implicitly think about the
cash how it works and then try to put
things in exactly as cash is supposed to
work so you will be ready for that ok
for GPU you must explicitly stage data
into the cache and keep it in the cache
as long as you need it but there is this
chicken and an egg question right you
design both your cash algorithm and both
your computational algorithm and where
to start first right just from the
mythological perspective this is kind of
question that should be answered so from
our experience the kind of workflow that
one should use and keep in mind when
designing these algorithms is first of
all one has to devise an algorithm with
temporal locality because no matter what
your cash logic is if you are not
temporarily local nothing would help no
cash would help in this case now then
you devise your caching algorithm
according to the cache access pattern
that you have in mind in your
computational algorithm and the key
point here is to reduce the overhead of
implementing the cash in software next
thing is that you do you take your
cereal written with you which is very
local and optimized for locality and you
optimize data reuse within each set of
threads so because as we've seen this
shared memory is shared among going to
result subset of threads and the threads
have to work collaboratively on this
piece of memory and this is the main
challenge that is totally different from
the one that we have in CPUs
and then you do kind of multiple pass
over this workflow trying to adjust
things now I guess you what makes you
wonder is imagining your temporal
locality but what about special locality
so essentially special locality seems to
be not that important because you have
this you know caching algorithm your
self so you can handle that in the
algorithm of your cash but there is a
catch if you are not special to local
all this prefetching stuff that's gone
on must it will just be very very slow
because GPU has access to Perl blocks of
memory and if your accesses are not what
said coalesced so that you fully utilize
the bandwidth in that case no way you
would get maximum out of the bandwidth
that you get from the global memory okay
so you must be also special local right
so with this workflow in mind what's
left right we have locality so what do
we need to do in the cash what do we
need to do in software replacement
policy right you want know what you
bring in what we leave what we pin in
and then what we move out okay so we
need to handle capacity and conflict
misses here right but think of deciding
this on demand in GPU curve these are
inherently serial decisions to make this
would just ruin the performance so what
we can do we can pre-compute it
depending on the input and then plug it
in in the generic mechanism that we
already implement as a part of the curve
so for different functions we may have
different amount of data in the cache
and basically what we implement here is
read-only direct mapped cache where
output is not cash because it's not
reused and
input is cash in a certain way where we
exact but know exactly what the amount
of data from each function we gonna use
in this particular set of threats so we
build our cash in a way where each
function is cached with different amount
of data right and this set of data we
call cache page because this is the set
of data that one thread block is going
to work on so here we're already see
that the logic of accessing functions in
different places is generic what we only
need to know is where each function is
resigning and this logic is pre computed
on a cpu before the computation and plug
in into the Eldred so briefly what do we
need to cash in our cache page so think
of three functions like that and think
of the cache page being four variables
so we want to cache all these data that
is accessed when we do all the
permutations of this sorry four
variables so the size of the cache
depends on the number of variables that
we select and the size of the cache in
this particular case is assuming that
each variable has two values so it will
be four for this it will be eight for
that and eight for their okay these
values we're going to cash for each
thread and what changes between the
thread blocks these values outside of
this window so between the thread blocks
we will permit eight over all possible
values of x y and x 6 now as you can see
the composition of the expected cash
sighs well they are input dependent
right so the size of the cache is input
dependent is dictated by the input but
what if in this case
we're going to cross the boundaries of
the available shared memory so we
compute that in this way because this is
dictated by the logic of the program but
now the rural cache size is 16 x 4 bytes
what if our memory is only sing sing
bytes what do we do now ok so these are
capacity misses right because we are
kind of we have more data to catch than
we have space for so what we can do we
can kind of you know check that there is
no data every time we access something
and if we were accessing it so if it's
not there we will prefetch that but it's
very expensive you would ruin all the
benefit of having cash in place so
instead we go and say all right we will
precompute the cache misses that we're
going to get because of the capacity and
we will avoid putting those functions
that cross the that cause this required
cash space to be large we would avoid
cashing them all together and by doing
that we want to select the set of cell
functions that minimizes the total
expected cache miss rate ok so this can
be reduced to a very very simple binary
knapsack problem which can be where
easier istics can give you factor of 2
to the optimum as you can see we solve
this binary naps a problem on a CP and
we plug that in to the GPU code
depending on the input so the very
simple perl compute structure is that
every thread handles one output and in
handling one output it acts as a certain
amount of data as we have seen this data
is cached ok now different threads work
collaboratively on this piece of data to
reuse it efficiently and to avoid
thrashing of this sketch
the interesting thing here is that we do
not have any cash conflicts why because
different threads discard the cash when
they cross the block boundary and we
cash all the data that will be accessed
in one block in one thread block so by
having all the data cashed in one thread
block and discarding it across the block
boundaries we make sure that there are
no cache conflict it's not efficient
because we increase the cache miss rate
in this way okay and I'll show in a
minute that we can improve that so what
is the colonel structure it turns out
that this is fairly typical Colonel
structure that one can find in many
kernels and you definitely seen
something like that so first you compute
which chunk you're going to work on then
you populate your cash and then you go
from zero to the number of summation
values that you want to each raid over
and for each summation value you iterate
over the functions that you have and
when you're accessing the function you
ask yourself whether the function is in
the cache or not and if it is then you
just get it from the cache and if it is
not then you get it then you get it from
the main memory so the essential so once
you get this value you just you know
aggregate the values of different
functions in the internal iteration and
then you sum over all the summation
values okay if you think of that this is
exactly the code for matrix
multiplication and simplistic way okay
when you just sum over the same
dimension but it is general for any
number of functions that you may have
and then after you've done that you just
axes the output in and put it in right
okay
so as I said we didn't have cash
conflicts because we ensure that our
threads x is the same the same piece of
data and they never access different
cash pages but as I said there is this
problem of increased cache miss rate
because of that because across the block
boundaries we just lose everything that
we pre fetched so what we can do now we
can improve this by realizing that we
can do several cash pages in the same
thread block but then some of the
functions would have to be reload how do
we know which functions to reload well
you might have guessed that we decide
that on cpu and plug that in interest
GPU another thing is that if you have
too many summation values your cash is
going to be is going to explode right
because every function has to have all
the summation values pre fetched and if
you have too many of them well no way
you would be able to make it so what you
can do is and what everyone does in
matrix world is splicing right it's
dialing so you can tile your input
across many different invocations so in
the first Colonel invocation you are
dealing with the first part and then you
invoke your kernel second time and
aggregate with the previous colonel on
vacation so the interesting question to
ask here is how to determine the tiling
silence because essentially if you have
this tiling and each of your tiles fits
memory but Colonel vacation is very very
short then you're going to miss all the
benefit of having your data cached
because the overhead of Colonel location
would dominate this benefit so there is
some heuristics that we apply to
determine the tile size and to predict
the expected Colonel vacation time and
try to
optimize that so there is one catch
though the catch is that we are trying
to plug in the data from CPU to be used
during the cache population rate
populating the cash now when we populate
the cash where do we get the metadata
from well from memory so what that means
that means that we are trying to access
to improve the access to slow memory by
making it even slower because we add
more memory accesses on the way too bad
right so what we can do we can use
texture and concert memories here
because some of them are cached some of
them reuse the bandwidth Lord on the
main bus like texture memory and what we
and and this is really helpful so when
we use that and we also reuse the same
data many time from the first memory
from the scratchpad we amortize the
overhead of accessing the slow memory in
order to push everything to the cash
another thing is that we were forced to
do dynamic loop unrolling as you can see
the loop is from the from 0 to the
number of summation variables right so
we don't know how many summation
variables we're going to expect so what
we can do we can do dynamic loop
unrolling you're tiling where we just
where we just have a look at how many
left and we unroll it four times there
are more than four values left and we
unroll it two times so essentially we do
this factorization of the number of
remaining iterations and do the best we
can for enrolling that unrolling it
aggressively ruins the performance
because some of the registers are
spilled out to the global memory so we
got to we got to the interesting part
right so these are the results small
worrying these results are from the old
invocation but we
have some brandy results and I wonder
whether you're going to see the catch in
them I mean they're too good to be true
but maybe you can find the problem so
hard word single core cpu intel core two
you know with large cash and GPU GI t i
see no matter how memory had i mean this
is the classical old first generation
CUDA card good is it 10 1.0 and we
actually tried it with the our own cpu
kernel and this kernel a performed quite
well in atlas so if when you consider
that this is not just regular matrix
multiplication but kind of a lot of
other overheads involved there with
index computation all that getting
within five percent from atlas is not
that bad we had two implementations one
is linear scale another is log scale so
log scale is essentially we wanted to
avoid under flows and to remind you the
our input was from probabilistic network
so things are below one so if you
multiply too many times and then sum
over too many times you lose you get
zero sometimes although it's definitely
not so in order to avoid so the trivial
way to avoid overflow is under flow is
to use log scale and this is quite often
used essentially although it's extremely
inefficient so if we just so what we do
we switch multiplication by summation
summation x x a and log and then we just
pre process all the data beforehand and
map it to the log scale so the
interesting part so definitely I would
want to stop here and say okay this is
my performance but that would be unfair
so transcendental functions on GPU are
mapped to special function units therapy
formed in hardware so when we got this
nice speed up Pico though but still
three orders of magnitude speedo
well we thought that you know there is
some problem with the computations of
the spirit it cannot be true so then we
ran a lot of micro benchmarks just
trying to understand where this speed up
comes from and it turns out that in this
case order of 25 is direct consequence
of using software manage cash without it
we lose the performance x factor for 25
factor of 2 is just by using the
hardware okay just by using GPU in down
way is better than using cpu and front
row 25 is because of special function
unit so essentially x f more or less six
times slower than summation on the GPU
and 200 times slower on the cpu okay so
there is a factor of a more or less say
35 between the speed-up obese pinned
between the speed of this particular
thing so when you get a lot of
transcendental functions this what makes
a huge difference now you know that as
special function unit its abilities are
limited the reasons only one special
function unit / / the set of a years for
16 years piece but and this has been
dramatically improved in the latest
generation of CUDA but of the cards but
even here it's quite amazing now on
average as you can see the performance
is not as bright as we would want it to
be and the worst case is really
devastated why is that well as we also
the reuse determines the expected
performance so if our input doesn't have
any reuse we just saturate the bandwidth
so we are out of luck we got bad input
so we just should not run it on the cpu
focus on a GPU full stop this is the
decision that we going to get to make
before running this in a production
setup however ously in some cases is
definitely where as well now there's a
single precision performance on this
card so this is the bottom line yes
very country what does what does vary in
the included ok so I'll show you on this
graph this is kind of a bizarre graph
with a lot of points in it you know just
to confuse you so one point is one
kernel vacation and the colonel well the
the input actually has a huge influence
on the cpu code as well as you see
because what we very eight here is the
number of input functions the number of
values per function the number of
overlap what we call between different
functions in terms of the number of
variables between them so we perform
more or less four hundred runs in
different you know combinations of those
those and this is what we get so this is
log scale right so as you can see the
average is indeed more or less 15
gigaflops but the interesting thing is
that here on this very car we get
bandwidth if we just map the best
performance to the bandwidth that would
be required for that performance we got
to 12 gigabyte per second which means
that the original bandwidth could not
have been squeezed and stretched to this
size right so all cash is actually doing
well alright but ok so here here's the
graph as you can see there is this part
of it that is not really good for GPU
and as you might have guessed the reason
is that there is just not enough power
Elizabeth the data to saturate the GPU
and here as you can see there is this
boundary point of 50 kilo flops in the
input which you know makes the
difference between CPU and GPU and this
is more or less the multiplication of
two matrices 40 by 40 ok so it's pretty
small input if you think of that
so how how is our model working on this
particular thing so if we just take our
model and map the expected results and
those that we get in practice by
changing the cache size okay until 16 k
okay so what we can see is first of all
that our model is more so the
approximation is quite good i mean the
tendency is exactly what we see with the
curve right i mean absolute values are
totally off right because we don't
account for all these overheads of the
colonel of the of different things but I
mean what we would want to get from this
is the upper bound and this is very
strong upper bound that you cannot cross
right and what we want to get is whether
it's worthwhile to increase the cache
size in order to optimize to improve the
performance and we clearly see that we
can do that by improving increasing the
cache size so we see the tendency we see
the global picture of what we're going
to get just from the model the numbers
are two optimist you can do okay as you
can see there are several knees here
right so what are these knees recall
that in our cash we decide whether to
cash will not to cash whole function
right so at this stage we got zero
functions in the cash here we got jump
because we managed to squeeze in one
function here we managed to squeeze in
two and here three okay and this is the
maximum that we could have get right
another is the number of cash pages per
thread lock right recall we have this
problem of cache misses every time we
discard the whole cache page and switch
to another thread block so now we try to
see how many how much improvement we get
from having multiple cash pages per
block so so as
can see the model actually predict
something that is beyond the earlier
performance right so it's really off but
again if you reduce factor of 10 more or
less you can see that this is the
boundary line where we increasingly
cache sizes me not getting any
improvement because basically we are not
using cash so this is kind of a
validation curve that says okay this is
not an artifact this is a true because
of cash and probe so on this graph you
can see that this is logarithmic scale
again so we are starting with from from
20 something and we get as far as a 3
with 34 35 by changing the number of
cash pages and our theoretical model
actually shows that this is what going
to happen and this is the comparison of
having no cash using texture for you
know hardware cash that the reason the
cat in the texture cash and our cash
okay for specific input we're just we go
and increase the number of summation
variables and by that increasing the
complexity and cpu we borrow lee see it
here in the bottom yeah yeah yeah yeah
that's you know lecturer said that it's
a good question because he has announced
so this is a good question and the
reason is is that if you can you know
just have a look there is clear periodic
periodicity here and the reason is that
we are hitting band conflicts bizarre
band conflicts here because the data is
aligned in a way that increasing the
number of summation values at some point
gets to all the banks access I mean one
bank access by all threads in the block
so it's kind of the worst possible band
conflict one can get and as you can see
texture texture cash
presents exactly the same problem it's
also missing here because of this
problem because of Bank context so you
may also ask what happens here and this
would also be good question and the
answer is that you can see that
something bad happened and this bad
thing is that we had to drop one
function out of the cash so by reducing
only one one function we kind of go
exactly like regular texture cash now if
you think of the texture hash cash has
some well it's not exactly fair to
compare us with texture cash because
texture cash is also shared among
different slab blocks right whereas our
cash is discarded it across thread block
boundary and that's why having texture
cash here behaving like that means two
things first of all it means that we are
not doing we are doing a good job with
the metadata so the overhead is actually
quite low because the hardware cash
behaves even worse than we do right and
another thing is that hardware has some
advantages over our thing over our
social managed get and still we are
getting bad even in the worst case of
bizarre band conflicts now this is the
effect of loop unrolling and as you can
see compiler is doing very bad job on
unrolling this look and we actually had
to well in my my current implementation
I have 20 different kernels enrolled in
all different combinations of summation
values and number of entrances now it
turns out that there is another
parameter of using texture cash for the
input where this parameter is also also
requires different kernels so I have 40
different terms generated automatically
by my scripts and compiled it okay
because the compiler doesn't do a good
job
on enrolling my loops and you see that
the benefit is huge now this is the new
brand new data more or less yes
degenerated and it might be a little bit
difficult to follow so i'll explain
there I did each graph is actually an
average over 100,000 runs of the curl
over large variety of input parameters
where I actually run over up to six
functions and up to 500 summation
variables and this is the input
complexity this is the effective
throughput in gigaflops double precision
on gtx 285 so the average performance of
the colonel can I measured several
combinations so first of all I tried
software manage cash with tiling and
software manage cat without tiling you
remember tiling I split the input into
multiple colonel location if it doesn't
feed the cash i also used combination of
softener manage cash and texture so
essentially my input is mapped to the
texture memory I fetch it and then put
it into my cash right so this way I
wanted to you know to squeeze most out
of it this is the boundary line of
having no cash at all and this is no
software cash but only texture okay so
let me follow here this is the boundary
average performance that we get when we
have no cash at all okay this is roughly
16 gb flop this is the cash this is this
the case where we do not have any tiling
and we are using only software cash
without texture this case is the one
where we are using software and texture
with styling so it's kind of combination
of all and this blue is software cash
without tiling but this is the best
we can get and this is software and
texture without Eileen okay and red is
software and texture with tiling alright
so what we see from these graphs is
actually two things first of all double
precision even an average double
precision performance is quite well
combination of all our methods together
is doing not bad if you consider the
comparison without tiling then it's it's
actually impressive now the reason why
without tiling works sometimes better
than with is because the overhead of
tiling is heuristic alee predicted and
this heuristics is sometimes off now
this is the average performance now this
is the best performance okay so as you
can see we kind of saturate the double
precision unit completely now what may
make you wonder is that sometimes we
saturated over its theoretical peak
right and this is something that I
realized only today and I was thinking
about it and you know checking the code
I realised that the complexity
computation doesn't take into account
than you improvement that they have in a
compiler and what compiler does whenever
I do i equals i plus i equals i plus
plus or i equals be a a equals B I'm
sorry a plus equals B and a is
statically defined above it as equals 1
or 0 essentially zero in this case it
doesn't it doesn't do plus it just
somebody just puts it okay the previous
compiler didn't do that now if I take
that into account I lose more or less
fifteen percent of that so I check that
I didn't have time to put it on graphs
but this is the before
that I'm expecting so even fifteen
percent less than that is still not bad
I would say so it's 60 so I'm not
saturating it done deal yet but close to
that now what about single-precision
just to compare that with the you know
with the single precision on g80 so it's
actually quite impressive we get there
we got the best performance this is the
best this is the average case so just
just to explain right this is best with
software and texture this is the best
with this is this is the best that's
right just let me find out what what's
going on here so this is using only
texture average and this is only texture
maximum and this is using software
maximum and texture together so all our
stuff combined so as you can see first
of all we improved from fifty gigaflops
maximum to almost 125 gigaflops Monte
maximum single precision doing
particularly nothing to improve that
just you know putting it into an another
generation card another thing is that
without using the cash this is the
average and this is the maximum so the
difference between the maximums is still
quite large okay so this is so my my
conclusion from that is that next
generation of hardware would give me for
free hopefully quite a lot of
performance benefits and this
scalability to another you know this
ability to just put it to another piece
of hardware and get this fit up well
it's nice and most of it is because of
the bandwidth improvements in G 285
versus and also not only been with as a
matter of fact there are several other
things but
I mean bandwidth is really dominating
further here so what you didn't ask an
ideal answer is the overheads right I
consider only the performance of the
kernel itself as if all the data is
there but if you think of that we have
the kernel that has kind of pipeline
right so we have to move data back and
forth and if you think if you consider
the overheads so this graph shows that
for up to here as long as our cache is
behaving greatly and fits and all the
data fits in the kernel of the colonel
execution time is actually comparable
with the time to prepare the metadata on
the cpu for this sketch so essentially
if we just go you know in
straightforward way and for every
invocation we move the data back and
forth and prepare the metadata and then
involve the colonel and then so all
these graphs would be nothing at the
application level so the first part
conclusions and I will be finishing
about five minutes saying may I may I
take another three minutes of your time
I hope so the use of shared memory is
good thing okay at this in this work we
try to do cash decisions on cpu for the
runtime on GPU but what if we have like
ray tracing is there any chance of
having this type of architecture for ray
tracing well i believe no way because if
you have random access and you cannot
predict that no way that you would be
able to do that on GPU well fortunately
folks at nvidia realize that and design
hardware cash so we'll see how it works
when it goes out okay so just to remind
what we were working on we were working
on an application that had different
kernel and vacations where each kernel
was pipelined into the next invocation
in the form of three so they
free was kind of traversed in the
reverse DFS in plastic so you start here
and here you cannot go up because you
have dependencies so then you have to
satisfy these dependencies by computing
this kernel then that and it cetera and
only by the end all the leaves are
computed and then you go forward so we
perform pretty well on on 16 8 slot
machine with with 16 CP years through
OpenMP with the same type of approach
kind of we do all the same logic with
with the without actually prefetching
data but the locality properties of our
computational algorithm still maintain
on gtx 285 the complete application
again this is only kind of preliminary
results we we didn't have a chance to to
run a lot of inputs so for this input we
get factor of 37 versus single CPU which
is more or less factor of well two and a
half vs. 16 cpu machine and if you
compare price performance then you
definitely realize that this is not too
bad Andrea this was the 8800 order no no
this is this is a new one yeah this is
the this is GTS 225 so so so the point
is that we are not losing anything
almost you know average performance that
I shown you on the graphs and the reason
is twofold one thing that we do is that
we maintain all the data on a GPU we do
not move it back and forth this of
course creates some problems with the
data with the memory management because
sometimes the amount of data cannot be
fit into GPU so you have to swap in and
out so we implemented some type of
software swapping here and another thing
that we do if you saw this graph where
GPU is worthwhile or not so on some
cases CPU just works better right and
what we do where
German by some heuristics currently and
we have already better algorithm now but
we'd still not implemented where r to
execute the input depending on the input
parameters on the CPU or GPU and you see
that what we have to also take into
account in our algorithm it this is the
next stage is that we have memory
transfers here so we cannot just
arbitrarily decide that we execute
something on a cpu and not on a GPU
because on the CPU it performs better
because by doing that we also may
require some merit to be transferred and
this would ruin whole benefit of using
this or that another thing is that that
in when when measuring the overheads you
may have seen that the overhead of
creating all this metadata is very high
for many kernels so what we do we run
this computation in two threads one
thread is managing GPU and another
thread is preparing the data for GPU in
this way we can traverse this tree and
also on the way paralyzed and utilize
both cpu and GPU and the last piece of
information that i want to deliver now
quickly is the use of two bomb and so
what sue bomber is to obama is a huge
cluster with a lot of very fast engine
connect infiniband based tons of storage
attached and 620 GPUs plugged in there
tesla's and 16 8 slot nodes
so what we did in su bomber we actually
did two level / realization one level
was to split this huge workload into
small independent business with low
overhead relatively low paralyzation
overhead but this made it embarrassingly
paarl now this is the same type of
approach we use and grids for this
workload and then on the node level we
invoked it either on 8 CP years so we
splittin out essentially evenly between
eight cpus or on a GPU right there were
two GPUs attached to announce so we had
16 outs with 16 CPUs and to Tesla GPUs
attached this brings it to a nice number
of thousands of so this is the the idea
we had a single master he has he
maintained the queue and we splittin out
into four independent parts and a GPU
got its own workload and this was our
way to manage heterogeneity of this
machines so the preliminary results and
again this is not really something that
I'm proud of because there are a lot of
Road room for for improvement but on a
single CPU we got like 5.5 CPU years for
this workload would be required whereas
on the speed up here was more or less
2487 now this number means nothing in a
sense that what really is important is
what we get from GPU right so
essentially if you think what speed up
you get you get more or less that one
GPU is equivalent to 16 CPUs so we got
more or less than this on this input we
got more or less factor of 16 on a GPU
versus single it versus 16 CPUs now
again I'm saying this is not something
that I'm really proud of there is a lot
of things that I can do here and
probably I will and this work is
sponsored by you guys and thank you so
much for having here and I would take
some questions there
have a few minutes so probably tried to
solve seems seems all identical to the
people way back then trying to math on a
machine with 61 64 K and a hard drive
and the numbers are longer but the
racials may be similar is there anything
any their home when you could do
Bastille so you're talking about out of
core computations like you the gold
freakin cold oh yeah so so essentially I
should confess I I'm not really familiar
with this work from what I heard and I
asked before reading something I asked
people who know it seems that the
trade-offs were really different so the
ratios were kind of different so I
cannot really probably some techniques
can be borrowed and this is something to
work on soon as you views get to l1 l2
cache
what's going to be the marginal benefit
still using suffocation
I think the benefit will be quite
substantial because tax your cash that
i'm showing here is not really cash it
doesn't reduce the latency it just
improves the bandwidth essentially but
it doesn't reduce latency and l1 will
definitely use the latency of access to
the data so i expect real significant
benefit from that however you never know
because on on the New York actually you
would be able to split between 16 / 116
Kol 10 and 48 k of of scratch pad or
vice versa and who knows maybe you know
maybe maybe in my case it would be
worthwhile in some cases to go to my
software manage cash and would be for
better because I don't know what
replacement policy would be on l1 cache
that's right I think that might be key
here because now one cash doesn't really
understand the structure guess that
makes be more creative
you might be catching something for a
longer term that
yes that's true but on the other hand if
you look at what I'm getting from
texture cash seems like I'm still
getting something from there and it's
really you know it's clearly beneficial
so I don't know I don't know I i I'm
very curious to see use the sizes of the
fish Akash's I have no idea about the
size of texture cash I know that the
working set is supposed to be 8k I
didn't see any correlation between my
amount of data that I'm accessing with
this 8k I don't know how this texture
cash works indeed and the amount of
shared memory that I was working with
there's exactly the same as in GA T what
is different though is the number of
registers allocated per thread so this
workload with texture and my cash stuff
requires 30 in some cases 28 registers
and one would not be able to get that
from g80 okay you would get all your
registers filled out and this would ruin
everything so that's why I was able to
do this experiment
of the spire system have you describe
the bucket the bucket is essentially
mapped to two things there is a metadata
describing which variables over bucket
they were there and there is this data
ok so the variables are fetched from
another large array of all the variables
so each function had kind of array
pointers where these the right variables
and there were some you know
computations beforehand quite nasty ones
you know to find the indexing but it's
not a big deal just them selves are can
functions the functions themselves
themselves over the over the elemental
matrix they they erase but they're just
a raise yeah because it's discrete
variables so they're just raised
no thank you very much